[Music]
in today's morning rounds the challenge
of living with epilepsy today did you
know his international epilepsy day the
condition affects about 3.4 million
people in this country roughly 1 in 26
people will develop it in their lifetime
but many living with epilepsy hide it
that includes successful fashion
entrepreneur Camila Coelho now she is
sharing her private battle in her first
TV interview since revealing the news
she spoke with our doctor Tara nurullah
Tara good morning - a lot of people are
glad she's speaking up yes they are good
morning Gail epilepsy is a neurological
disorder characterized by unpredictable
seizures but the severity of those
seizures can vary from person to person
for some living with the stigma of the
condition could have more of an impact
on their lives than the seizures
themselves Camila Coelho says she's
speaking out in hopes of changing others
perceptions Camila Coelho is a rising
star in the fashion and beauty industry
to me she walks exclusive red carpets
works with major designers I love this
and launched her own namesake fashion
line last year how many do we need to
choose along the way she shared every
detail of her life with her more than
eight and a half million Instagram
followers
except for her epilepsy diagnosis at age
9 were plain and my hands started
closing by itself and that's when I
fainted and I had my seizure it was like
I went to sleep and the next thing I
hear is my mom calling my name
sorry and I couldn't answer her how long
did it take before they diagnosed you
with epilepsy it was right away my mom
told me Camila no one needs to know this
like no one needs to know that you had a
seizure or do you have epilepsy and I
know my mom was trying to protect me you
know that was one of the reasons why I
never opened up Kawai oh who grew up in
Brazil started taking medication daily
but it said
several seizures since her diagnosis
more than two decades ago she moved to
the US as a teenager but continued to
hide her condition as her career took
off sometimes I would feel like people
would think I was a little crazy because
I had to take this medicine because I
had the seizure like something was wrong
with my brain epilepsy is a neurological
disorder that causes the brain to
produce sudden abnormal bursts of
electrical energy the resulting seizures
could be as subtle as someone staring
blankly into space - loss of
consciousness convulsions and with
certain seizures even death what's been
the most difficult part for you of
managing or having epilepsy the most
difficult time ice I would say would be
now thinking of having a baby her doctor
recently told Kawai oh and her husband
Iker oh that her seizure medication
could increase the risk of an abnormal
pregnancy but also explained she could
be at risk by going off the medication
because if you do have a seizure while
you're pregnant you could lose your baby
so I'm scared for now Kawai who is
continuing her medication making sure to
get enough sleep as tiredness can
trigger a seizure and exercising
regularly for someone who's gained a
following sharing her successes
she hopes now sharing her struggles will
make even more of an impact I made the
decision to talk about it because I
really believed that I could help
someone if I helped one person it's
already worth it for me
Kawai Oh says she's had to turn down
several professional opportunities to
make sure she gets enough rest and
manages stress
she says headaches are often a warning
sign of a possible seizure I'm glad
she's speaking up but that choice she
has to make with with kids is a really
hard one that's right and you said she
said it's the most difficult part of
having epilepsy the other most difficult
part she said it was not the suffering
herself but being concerned about how it
would affect her husband and her family
watching her have a seizure so and
seizures make people uncomfortable
because we don't know what to do exactly
so you want to stay calm make sure the
person's safe and important turn them on
their side if they're on the ground
something soft and small under their
head all right yep and call 911 or last
more than five minutes okay good advice
Tara thank you very much you can find
more information about epilepsy
including a link to the Epilepsy
Foundation on our website that CBS
Morning Calm